what's the number one what's the number
one article on top of yeah that would be
interesting what do you think let's
guess that's guessing Trump I'm gonna go
ahead with that out there okay well it
could be worth saying cuz it correlates
to Trump maybe it's what's-her-face be
me that story they're gonna have to be
ok lin-manuel Miranda stops metal
tariffs trigger retaliation for Mexico I
win
trade war yeah but leave that Samantha
be apologizes after white house can
condemnation calling Ivanka Trump a
vulgar word I went to forgiving her
they're forgiving her in that just think
of the headlines yeah she apologies and
she looks nice in that picture
are they forgiving her they're gonna
forget she apologizes after Compton
nation yeah call Ivanka Trump a longer
word why don't they just write can't
apologizes for airing the word oh they
did it on TV wait a minute wait a minute
it's on our TV show cut the [ __ ]
it's insane yeah that's TBS had to
apologize to TBS said [ __ ] no it was on
her shows on TBS but he said say [ __ ]
like the word I think they just
apologized for it no no I'm saying
did they air the actual word or did they
be I don't know that's a good question
because remember when Stephen Colbert
when he said he that Trump uses Putin
uses Trump's mouth for his [ __ ] holster
yeah they've said like that shit's crazy
that's what I know like that's what I'm
saying lose their minds just imagine
imagine the worst our black
conservatives like like them we get the
things that people say to us and what's
bizarre now is like white liberals like
they just feel comfortable say I'm like
why to like cuz it's like so weird
though right and they'll say anything to
me here goes
TBS networks makin is taking the right
action apologizing what for the vile and
inappropriate language used about a
vodka Trump last night those words
should not have been aired it was our
mistake to and we regret it
what is this I don't I do not like the
way they worded that right she's taken
the rights action so they they have a
positive
she attributed to her before that's what
you read when you read what how they're
going to interpret it washe was there
it's always gonna it's gonna be positive
but fired that's positive I'm not gonna
know because there's a double standard
there's a double standard and this is
why I fired Roseann when she had the
number one show in the country they just
threw away a lot of money with that one
yeah and and also you know and did a lot
of jobs for people that hook it up she
doesn't want to do it anymore
talking to Roseann yeah personally I
think she was so worn out from doing
that show she's 66 years old right you
know and she's not in the best of health
and she told me she got bronchitis doing
the show and she almost died she's like
I'm too [ __ ] old for this [ __ ]
right I can't do this anyway and they
were wearing me out